In "Black Panther: Wakanda Forever," the Talokanil
prove themselves to be not only skilled fighters
in the ocean, but also exceptional fighters
on land, even though they can't breathe air.
This is made especially clear during Okoye's
fierce battle with Attuma on the bridge in
Boston.
Generally speaking, the Dora Milaje wipe the
floor with all kinds of adversaries, including
super-soldiers.
However, Attuma's victory over Okoye in their
first fight is shockingly decisive.
Although she beats him in a rematch, the Talokans'
incredible skill is still firmly established.
Namor's fighting abilities can be chalked
up to his status as an amphibious mutant,
but that isn't the case with his blue-skinned
people.
So how did they become such good fighters
on dry land?
This is a people who have managed to stay
hidden from the surface world for centuries.
Why are they so well prepared to take land-dwellers
on if, for generations, there's been no need
to do so?
The end of "Black Panther: Wakanda Forever"
implies we'll be seeing a lot more of Namor
and his people in the MCU.
Maybe then we'll learn how these underwater
people got so good at fighting in the open
air.